first time I saw it was probably in high
school you know it's just one of those
images that you never forget it gets
seared into your memory
[Music]
Peter's known principally to us through
the famous photograph mostly known as
discouraged back the photograph which
was printed on a new technology at the
time is sort of like a postcard kind of
took off with a special issue of
Harper's monthly
accompanying that image was a story
about Peter escaping from slavery in
Mississippi covering himself and onions
to hide from The Bloodhounds that had
been set on this path being captured by
the Confederate Army
and then escaping capture from them
the kind of Escape that Peter had to
undertake was incredibly difficult
the landscape itself was like a prison
to escape the means you've got to Brave
the swamp with its storms malaria
dangerous animals and snakes it makes it
almost impossible to escape he makes his
way to the Contraband Camp he's taken
immediately to the medical examiner and
that's where the scourged back is
revealed
the image was able to circulate like
wildfire all throughout mostly the
Northeast but the broader American
society you see it in postcards being
sold on the streets of New York you see
it for sale through abolitionist
subscriptions here is for most people
incontrovertible evidence of the
barbarity that slavery necessitates of
what it demands to reduce a human being
to that level of acquiescence and
exploitation
this image was able to State plainly for
all the world to see that slavery cannot
endure without barbarity that is its
currency it requires that in order to
function
much of what we know about the story of
Peter comes from Harper's magazine but
the other evidence we have seems to
complicate that that this may have been
amalgamation by the writer of a bunch of
different stories that he'd learned from
covering slavery from covering the war
we have the most famous image of
American slavery on one hand and we know
next to nothing about him on the other
hand not even his real name that in a
nutshell is the historical problem with
understanding American slavery the kinds
of Records the kinds of archives we use
to write the lives of other people in
this Society just simply don't exist to
the same degree for enslaved people that
makes it very very hard to tell the
story of enslaved people in any great
detail so we have to try to read against
the grain and work our way through this
paucity of evidence to try to tell a
fuller life story of enslaved people and
that story in Harpers is still social
because it's a composite of what we have
come to learn about the greatest
Rebellion against slavery in American
history which is the mass defection of
slaves from the plantations during the
Civil War and the joining of the Union
Army that image was able to achieve a
sense of reality for many people who
continue to be skeptical about the
testimonies of ex-slaves in a sense you
could think of it as one of the first
viral images remaking the sensibilities
of Americans in relation to the cruelty
of slavery when Peter makes it to the
union lines he's immediately impressed
into the Union Army he knows another
kind of unfreedom right away Freedom
isn't going to be straightforward
despite all the heroicism despite the
sacrifice that's gone into getting this
far the journey is not over that I think
is the compelling task of a film like
emancipation it is about slavery and
it's about more than slavery it's about
The Human Condition this teaches us
something about what it means to be
human even now